LAND.
THANK YORY>> THANK YOU.
YOU JUST REITETEE Y YOU HAVE T
TIMELINE
H MEETINGDAY. ADD IT ALL UP, T.
A PNGER T
EKWE'L IT'S  O T
COUNTRY.
WE'RE VERY MUCH IN T WITH
TONY AND BO>> EA I T A TIME.
AEA
>>DATA
>> BASED A CERTAIN
LEVEL OFE ST HAPPENED TO
ARRIVE WINKING OF
TES SOONER.
I'D LOVE TO SEE I. YOU HAVE SEE
AN95 IN T4HOURS.
NEW YORK'SER THIS ISKE ARAIN RO
HANDLE THE CASEST THEY LYAPL.
WHAT AREEE ALL OF AD
COULDOPEN BRE'
AN BE ABOUT LARGECTOUNTRY BECAU
THERE'S SECTIONS THAT DIDN'T
THEY H VYID ERBLE T'TR TPENEW W
OTO QUESTION.
I THINK WE'REOI
INCREDIBLE L H ALSOIC
>>ND
FAUCI.
LOOKING ATHISDE ANEAKS A, WHAT
METRIC BY W WILLE CA U THIS ARE
CAN'T OPEN UP THAT NUMBER?
WILL Y LOOKINGSE
NUN? ATAR
PORTIONS OF OUR C AND WILL
BE GDE
DEBORAANF THE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WORKIT
TH YOU.
AT WOULD THINK THAT'S
GOAL TAPPEN OR
AT LEA VERY L COUNTRY.
WHERE AR NOW WITH TH TIMECENTER.
HHE IN T O A
VI I TO  THINGS WHEU SEEE
AC NCITY. TONO
ABOUTHAPENETRANCE IS
D OF TESTIWE'RE DOG WILL BE Y I
ISN AND CONTACT TRACG.YOU FIND
RE DFE AREAS OF THECOUNTRY,
YOU MAY NOT TREAT AS
JUST ONE FORCE F TIR
COUNTRY.ONG AT THE
WHAT WE
WNEED KNOW WHAHOSETHE COUNTRY R
BE C CMP LHERE YOU DON'T
REALLY HAVE TO BE ASARSH AS YOU.
L INFORMA
UPOINT WE NEVER HAD.
IT'S A.>> IS BECOMINE EICENTE N
IT'S VERY
THEY HADOUGH TIME THEMEHT WE'REM
TEG DONE IN
EIGHT WEEKS.
THAT TRN.
THE TEST I C BEST
ON OF D MORE THAN
ODY E HIGITY A BIG DIFFERENCE.
WE'L S LIKS BUT NEW YORK CITY I
HHOT
SPOT.
>> WHEN YOU TALK ABO COULD OPEN
STRE YOUKIABOUT? SOUTH?
>> THEBELT.
KE L FARM LK OUT
WE LOOK AT BIGECTIONSFWAS OUT TR
THEYAV SECTIONS OF T' NUMEROUANE
LARGETIONS OF --FEAY
LAS OF THEOPTHINK IT'S IMPTA TH
OUNTRYE
OUR PEOPLT OPEN
AND TY ARARINGOGO.
I THINK IT'S ONE OF REASONS
WE'LL HAVE A BOUNCECK.I THINK I
HE'S DUCHIN FOR THE JOB HE'
DONE.
HE'S A FORCE IN TERMS'SEENNTTIN
ING TERE.
I THINK THEY
I'LL SEE YOU ALL TOMORROW.
THANK YOU VERYMU
>> IS IHE PAC CHURCHES
ON EA RELATIVELYASSEME BY T
THE UNITED STATES.. IS PROGRESS.
A TREMENDOUS
A MUCH DIFFERENTPP FROMFAUCI.
HE SAYS YOU HAVE TO THE
DA AND STUDY.
UEA T
PROGRESS THAT'S BEI MADEE UNITE
STATES.
WEATED THAT.
T DEA THAT THE
PRESIDRA EASTER RESTRICTIONS WOL
ED THINKOULD BE
BACK TOAIOO
DATA. CLEAR WEEKROM NOHELOOKWORE
DISTANCING MEASURES WILLU WON'TO
STRICTIO'T MAKE
COULD WE S A SITUATION WHERE FOY
EVEN LON
ITP
AND D
THE15-DAY THAT'S NEXT